welcome to the future this is the
welding shop also known as the body
build area
it's a sea of robots 275 to be precise
that fuse together many of the stamp
parts of the car some of these robots
are enormous standing seven feet tall
and weighing 2,000 pounds
here one robot picks up an external door
panel while another one places an
internal panel on top then this robot
welds the two pieces together finally it
lifts the completed door and carefully
places it on to another power then it's
off to the main buck the main Buckholtz
the cars left right top and bottom sides
in place while the robots weld each of
the pieces together these robots perform
their tasks to within one one thousandth
of an inch the entire process takes less
than a minute
it's really starting to look like a car
now Marshall we're now at the end of the
actually body build process we've got
the shell of the vehicle 6000 Wellesley
thousand yes sir
and who do you think checks the accuracy
of the welds other robots
[Music]
these robots take pictures of 50 key
points on the automobile frame and
compare the welds to a computer model
the welds must match the model to within
one half of a millimeter if a frame
doesn't pass inspection its bumped off
the line and sent back for more welding
frames that pass inspection take the
high road over to the body complete area
where they're outfitted with doors the
hood and a trunk and now it's ready for
paint Marshall this is what we call the
Eco door electric coat system ecoute is
an electrically applied under coating
that protects the car from corrosion
workers bump up to 300 volts of
electricity through this liquid while
grounding the cars body
because opposite charges attract the
undercoat adheres to every square inch
why they're rolling by rolling the car
any dead air space any trapped air space
is going to be rotated through and we're
gonna have good even coverage of e-code
throughout the body after the car bodies
exit the electric code bath they travel
down another trestle into the first of
many painting rooms for the next nine
hours the cars will move down four miles
of a conveyer system lined with ninety
eight painting robots here they're
spraying a coat of primer next they
cover each frame with one of 15
different paint colors and finally they
apply a clear coat that provides shine
and protection to the vehicle
the next stop is the trim assembly shop
where man and machine finally come
together